[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres
le 5ème conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines hauts de
seine s'est tenue vendredi dernier
parmi les thèmes abordés la stratégie de
développement du tourisme qu'on s'a
mutualisation entre les deux
collectivités
et puis la semaine dernière la ville
demeure pas inauguré son nouveau skate
pas que cela fait suite au premier
budget participatif lancé l'année
dernière
cette initiative avait aussi déboucher
sur la rénovation de l'air de jeu du
poids de nos gens hors série épisodes de
après la gare saint-lazare s'était levé
le droit national de saint quentin en
yvelines qui accueillait la nuit de
l'électro amara trop de 14 heures de
musique qui a séduit les quatre mille
clubbers présents on ouvre ce journal
avec le 5ème conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines
hauts-de-seine qui s'est tenue vendredi
deux joints à jouer en josas à l'ordre
du jour la stratégie de développement du
tourisme et sa mutualisation un
reportage de nicolas d'entrée l'île de
france a attiré 46,7 millions de
touristes en 2015 un secteur majeur dans
le cadre du rapprochement entre les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine et cela à
travers une politique commune sur la
stratégie du développement du tourisme
des deux territoires
on a défini huit axes de travail sont va
pas les rappeler les huit mais il ya ce
que je vais dire le tourisme rural
le tourisme d'affaires le tourisme
hôteliers le tourisme patrimonial et
c'est le tourisme de la scène huit
priorités choisies après un travail
lancé en septembre dernier les membres
de la commission tourisme de le pays
yvelines hauts de seine ont rencontré
près de 150 professionnels du tourisme
pour connaître leurs attentes
le premier objectif c'était déjà de
faire un diagnostic de je dirais de la
complémentarité qu'il peut y avoir entre
le 78 92 avec versailles avec bien sûr
notre axe seine qui est quelque chose de
fondamental
et puis du côté du 92 également
avec la défense qui est un lieu aussi
d'un développement touristique
d'affaires qui est fondamental est
important avec ses deux pôles
touristiques les deux collectivités
partagent aussi la scène un site
stratégique pour développer des
activités pour les visiteurs nationaux
et internationaux avec en ligne de mire
le développement économique
ce potentiel simplement il doit être mis
en cohérence avoir une politique
d'ensemble pour le promouvoir
on voit bien que paris est saturé
d'ailleurs et donc il ya vraiment un
champ là qui est tout à fait important
producteur aussi d'emplois et de
croissance
il est normal que l'ouest parisien
cherche à récupérer à capitaliser sur
cette richesse cette stratégie
interdépartementale et portait sur
quatre ans entre 2017 et 2021
un point d'étape sur cette politique
sera effectué lors d'une assemblée en
2019 et la campagne des législatives
continue dans la première
circonscription télé perez est le
candidat du front national
cet homme de 50 ans et versailles est
depuis 30 ans souhaite véritablement
créer une opposition à emmanuel macron
c'est une circonscription qui est plutôt
à droite
je pense que beaucoup d'électeurs sont
un peu perdus et à juste titre parce que
des gens qui avaient l'habitude
traditionnellement de voter à droite se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec une partie des
candidats qui est la république en
marche et c'est pour ça que je compte
qu'il nous rejoigne
parce que il faut qu'ils comprennent que
une candidature patriote c'est leur
intérêt
l'intérêt de leur famille l'intérêt de
leur avenir l'intérêt de leurs enfants
leurs petits-enfants
c'est ça qui me paraît important
aujourd'hui et plusieurs réunions
publiques sont à noter la première
organisée par aurore bergé de la
république en marge candidate dans la
10e circonscription se déroule à 19
heures à la salle des mariages de bonnel
la deuxième est organisée par philippe
brillault le candidat des républicains
dans la troisième circonscription à
20h30 aux clayes-sous-bois à l'école
marcel pagnol
on referme cette page politique on prend
la direction de trappes la semaine 2
r un nouveau service de souvent destinés
à des enfants souffrant de troubles du
comportement a vu le jour grâce à
l'association pour l'insertion
l'éducation et les soins
nous allons aller chercher les jeunes
dans leurs lieux de scolarité pour leur
proposer un accompagnement avec une
équipe pluridisciplinaire et un plateau
technique composé d'éducateurs
spécialisés de psychologues
orthophonistes de psychomotricien et
d'éducateurs spécialisés
il ya aussi la possibilité d'aller au
sein des écoles faire une intervention
auprès de ces jeunes de manière à ce
qu'ils puissent rester dans
l'établissement scolaire et avoir une
prise en charge pour les aider et les
soutenir dans leurs difficultés
c'était l'année dernière la mairie de
maurepas faisait son premier budget
participatif cette initiative avait
débouché sur la rénovation de l'air de
jeu du bois de nogent et la construction
d'un skate park qui a été inaugurée la
semaine dernière ils sont à l'origine du
projet les jeunes de maurepas on rêvait
d'un nouveau style parc
il a été inauguré vendredi de juin
dernier l'ancien était très vieillissant
et même dangereux parce que j'ai dû le
faire fermer parce qu'ils avaient des
plaques métalliques qui se soulever et
donc après ça a été soumis au vote des
morts passe bien et plus de 200 votes se
sont prononcés sur ce projet et donc
voilà après on a engagé d un groupe de
travail que j'ai souhaité participatif
proposé lors d'un projet participatif et
d'un budget de moins de cent mille euros
la structure est en béton un matériau
pérenne une piste de 72 mètres de long
une dizaine d'éléments pourra aider ça
fait longtemps qu'on attend ça et puis
c'est au rendez vous ça ça glisse bien
ça roule bien
on a tout ce qu'il faut on est content
ce qu'on attendait depuis les années du
béton ce que tu vois le le bouton qu'on
a là bas c'est pas tip top
donc c'est cool qui en investissement
pour pour le skate park dès son
inauguration le skate park était pris
d'assaut le maire lui-même n'a pas pu
résister
saint cyr l'école a redonné vie au bois
cassé la semaine dernière un parcours
sportif et des attractions étaient
inaugurés au coeur du parc forestier qui
se situe entre saint cyr l'école et bois
d'arcy près de 400 enfants ont participé
à cet événement oui c'était une volonté
à la fois de la part des dessins sais
rien mais d arcy bien aussi et petit à
petit on a vu revenir les joggeurs et
c'est comme ça qu'en discutant avec les
joggeurs qui était à la fois
fontenaisiens arcisien saint cyrien on a
mis en place mi mis en oeuvre un projet
et ce week end a eu lieu les rendez vous
aux jardins en ile de france dans les
yvelines plusieurs domaines ouvert leurs
portes au public
c'était le cas à versailles avec le
domaine de marie antoinette
plusieurs visites étaient proposées dont
l'une réservée aux enfants
moi je m'appelle charlotte et vous les
enfants c'est pauline antoine jeanne et
anselme a reçu parti avait avec les
grands bonjour les grands aussi
puis c'est parti pour un étonnant voyage
dans les jardins du château de
versailles sous la conduite de notre
conteuse charlotte les enfants et leurs
parents sont conviés à une découverte du
domaine les fleurs les arbres les
animaux
tout est prétexte pour découvrir de
nouveaux contes et histoires
notre balade commence du côté du petit
trianon édifié par louis 15 avec ses
jardins anglo chinois
on s'imagine croisé marie antoinette au
détour d'un chemin
les pousses de louis saez trouvait en
effet régulièrement refuge dans ses
jardins
mais c'est un arbre fantastique qui nous
à nous y voilà
on raconte que si on passe dans le gros
trou qui est là on arrive on arrive en
chine comme ça pouf
la 15e édition des rendez vous aux
jardins en ile-de-france s'est tenu les
2 3 et 4 juin
le public était invité à découvrir ou
redécouvrir les parcs et jardins à
explorer les merveilles botanique et à
profiter de nombreuses animations
gratuites
comme cette visite guidée à versailles
mais des enfants veulent tentant de
l'histoire de cette princesse chinoise
qui ne souriait plus jusqu'à découvrir
la flore de thé perles de rosée notre
voyage nous entraîne vers d'autres
légendes d'autres jardins une rivière
anglaise une forêt d'écureuil mêmes
déragon là pour enfin arriver au grand
trianon où l'on retrouve un magnifique
jardin à la française
parfaite géométrie avec son alignement
d'arbres la nature et dompter pendant
une heure charles offshore a permis à
ses visiteurs petits ou grands de
voyager dans le temps et de
s'émerveiller de la beauté des fleurs
j'ai beaucoup aimé cette idée de faire
un voyage avec les enfants et il était
et c'était un vrai voyage un pas très
long mais qui qui nous a tous beaucoup
beaucoup plus et on passe en tout autre
sujet dimanche les cyclistes du
vélodrome de montigny le bretonneux ont
été remplacés par des clubbers six mois
après leur succès à la gare de paris
saint-lazare
les dj électro du collectif hors série
ont fait un marathon de 14 heures dans
l'enceinte sportive
regardez les vélos ont été rangés
remplacé par les platines
de dimanche à lundi le vélodrome
nationale a vécu 14 heures de concert
cinq artistes et groupes se sont succédé
[Musique]
trois heures de 7 pour un état dj
membres du blockhaus un collectif
promouvant la technique ça
quitte à revoir dans les clubs déjà et
puis je trouve que
ça va dans la logique de
la démocratisation de
de la techno d'être dans des lieux aussi
imposant emblématique pour paris c'est
important pour nous dans l'air centrale
un public venu de toute la france
montigny le bretonneux bien sûr mais
aussi où dans caen lyon paris ou encore
marseille
jara pour m'éclater avec mes potes ou
taper du pied et s'amuser comme on peut
pour faire la fête on a entendu il y
avait une soirée plutôt façon il y avait
des bonzes cette heure on est venu tout
de suite on adore la techno à tous du
coup on est venu pour vraiment s'éclater
toute la soirée je voulais faire la
série qui est à la gare saint lazare
j'ai malheureusement pas pu la terre et
j'ai eu des retours de monstrueux qui
était difficile et là j'ai vu là hors
série je me suis dit qu'il fallait
absolument que j'aille pas ce succès
donc pour ce deuxième rendez vous hors
série après la gare saint lazare en
septembre dernier près de 4000 personnes
ont dansé jusqu'au petit matin
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée
[Musique]